- [Instructor] In the last video,
we numerically studied how changes in
productivity or cost might affect
your marginal cost, your
average variable cost,
your average fixed cost,
or your average total cost.
In this video, we're gonna
think about it visually.
So, we constructed these curves several
videos ago to visualize
how average fixed cost
trends over time.
As you take that fixed
cost and you spread it
over more, and more, and more units,
you see that that just
asymptotes toward zero
as you get more and more units.
You see your marginal cost curve,
and this is something that you'll
typically see in a lot of textbooks.
It's kind of u-shaped.
And we talked about where it intersects
the average variable cost.
That's where the average variable cost
goes from trending down to trending up.
So it hits that minimum point,
and the same thing happens
at average total cost.
It hits the bottom of that
u of average total cost.
It goes from trending down to trending up.
And then over time, this
difference that you see
between your average total cost
and your average variable
cost, that difference
right over there, that is
your average fixed cost.
And so, since your average fixed cost are
asymptoting downwards, you see that this
difference between average total cost
and average variable cost
gets less and less over time,
that they are going to, over time,
converge to each other as your average
fixed costs gets closer, and closer,
and closer to zero.
But now let's think about how these curves
might be impacted if you have changes
in productivity or cost.
So let's start with a
change in your fixed costs.
Let's say your rent goes up.
What would happen then?
Pause this video and think about
what would happen visually.
Well then your average
fixed cost would shift up,
and it might look something like this.
Your average fixed cost might
look something like this.
And then, which of these other curves
also have fixed costs embedded in it?
Well, your average total
cost is a combination
of your average variable cost and
your average fixed cost.
So the amount that your
average fixed cost went up
for any quantity, your
average total cost would
also go up that amount for that quantity.
So it would look something like this.
It would look something like this.
And once again, just as before,
it will trend downwards
until you intersect
with your marginal cost curve.
And then it'll start trending upwards.
So a change in your fixed costs,
either upwards or downwards,
would affect your average fixed cost
and would affect your average total cost.
The reason why it doesn't affect
your average variable cost is because
your average variable cost are taking out
out your fixed costs.
They're just thinking
about the variable costs.
And your marginal costs are thinking about
a difference in costs
between two different
states of output.
And the fixed costs
are in either of those,
so they will cancel out.
What would be a change
in your variable costs?
Let's say you have to give
everyone a pay increase.
Well then your variable costs will go up.
And your variable costs might look like
something like this.
They will just shift up.
And once again, they will trend downwards
until you intersect with
your marginal cost curve,
and then you will trend upwards.
Now, a change in your variable costs
will also affect your marginal costs.
Because as you produce more output,
well then you are likely to incur
more incremental costs.
So then your marginal costs,
and I know this is getting very messy,
might start looking something like,
might look something like that.
So, big picture, changes in productivity
would likely affect your
average variable cost,
likely affect your marginal cost,
and of course, average variable cost
feeds into average total
cost, so that would be
impacted as well.
But changes in just your fixed cost
would affect your average fixed cost curve
and your average total cost.